Chứ này ngày 20 năm năm 2018, công tác cứ hộ nạn nhân dây số hỗ素 lốn tại sát kinh lưu.
Vậy nâng gì, mắc cả vẫn đang được lực lượng chức nào hình chương trình 2.
Phương án bơ nứ khỏi hỗ đất đất viên thành, tuy nhiên, sau có mạnh nước hầm đi mất nhiều thế gián thần sự kiến.
Chứ đó, và tối qua, người bà xế mấy lào số hỗ tự thành năm dưới giải phân cách thuốc quốc lộ BAB.
Trong sáng ngày, lực lượng chức năng của tình bắc cảnh và việc nâng gì đã chỉ khai nhiều biệt pháp tình kiến, cứu nạn nhẹn chương có kết quả?
Được biết, hỗ tự thành này xuất hiện tự đêm 3 mi tám, giá sáng ngày 20 năm 2018, chiến của lộ BAB đã qua sát kinh lưu.
Mà đầu, hỗ素 có chiều dài khoảng 7 mế, sau năm mẽ, năm sữa dài phân cách,
tuy nhiên, theo thời gian khốn mấy càng bởi giọc, bên dưới đại hỗ lốn có mạnh nước nồng và hảm ếc.
Mặc dù hàng chăm mếc hỗ đất đã đất đổ xuống, nhưng vẫn không thể lập đầy được hỗ tự thành này.
Cơ quan chức năng đã tiến hình khoanh tổ phù phục vi nhiên và đất viện cạnh báo.
Hình không có kết quả nạn vẫn đang được các lực lượng chức năng khẩn chương trình khai.